hey guys how's it going welcome to an
ask I J episode I know this wall looks a
little familiar if you guys have seen
any of my unboxing videos this is
usually where I do my unboxing videos I
also a fun fact you used to do a lot of
my ask IJ episodes on a blank wall
welcome to the first episode of ask AJ
let's get that first question out of the
way but then I just got lazy and now I'd
kind of do them wherever I feel like it
so today's ask i J is brought to you by
you guys I asked you guys on Twitter
some questions and you gave me a lot of
material to work with so let's say I
first start out here Gus wants to know
how many dongles do I own I uh I've got
a few dongles I guess for me on an
everyday basis my most important dongle
is my lightning to headphone ox through
a five millimeter
dongle boy that was that thing so many
times I've already gone through several
but now I have a special safe place on
my desk where anytime I find it I put it
back in its safe place so I do not lose
the dongle any longer and here's the
suppose and safe place the irony is
guess what
not a single dong look as far as how
many I have I'm not sure I've got
dongles for days Helberg music wants to
know who is my favorite Swedish EDM
artists under 25 is and there's a wink
at the end I'm assuming judging by this
tweet that you want me to say use of
course I'm going to say you so you win
help her at ouzo it's kinda lame for me
the GoPro is recalling all of its karma
drones back and yes this is true he
wants to know if I'm going to be
returning mine and yes I am actually
going to be returning it as soon as I
can I'm waiting for information back
from GoPro on how to do the return
process
apparently the GoPro drones have been
falling from the sky due to power
failures that's what they're saying the
overall problem is that really we don't
know what the whole problem is but this
is a mandatory recall they're saying if
you purchase this drone you have to
return it you can't just keep it even if
it's working fine they also said that
they're doing a full refund even if you
bought the GoPro care which is their
protection plan and any accessories to
go with it but it's
crazy because usually when you do
recalls and things like this sometimes
they will offer to send you another
product they won't actually give you
your money back with GoPro saying no
we're not sending you another drone
we're giving your money back like that's
it
whatever the drone is available for
purchase again we'll let you know will
it be available for purchase will it be
in the same sort of drone form factor
that they currently have it will it be
something completely different
I don't know all I know is I really did
try to make a karma work I bought the
extra propellers I couldn't bring myself
to honestly even put them on because
using this thing it wasn't as fun as it
was when flying any other drone
especially the Mavic I just I know I
keep doing this comparison to it but
it's such a freaking incredible drone
not even comparing the GoPro Karma to
the Mavic it's kind of embarrassing
so either way I'm so sorry - GoPro and
everyone involved on the karma team I
love GoPro so it was extremely very very
sad for me as well to sort of just see
that all kind of just literally fall
from the sky I wish them the best luck
in their next version and I hope that it
all works out well because because it's
just not good for anybody
Madelyn wants to know my favorite year
r'mante flavour is it currently is the
blue 40th but it's also kind of tied
with the rebel berry so I kind of go
back and forth between the two Carly Rae
wants to know what's a good camera to
start for taking photos and videos and
this is going to be kind of crazy like I
would honestly 100% recommend you just
get an iPhone because it takes
incredible photos it does really good
video and you can basically do
everything that you need to do on your
phone so if you're looking to become a
youtuber the easiest way to do it is
right here in the palm of your hand
Megan once another type of videos I
enjoy filming and editing and creating
the most vlogs cooking gameplay drone
shots it's kind of hard because I would
get bored if I just did one sort of
video so the fact that I do so many
different things completely just keeps
me entertained and engaged and I still
enjoy doing all of them if I go and
start editing a bunch of cooking videos
and be like this is boring if I start
editing a bunch of logs as this is
boring so the best part about it is I
kind of everyday I'm editing something
new and something different so for me
it's fun and I hope that you guys enjoy
it too I'm curious to see what are your
favorite types of videos because I know
I have people that are fans of
sorts of videos maybe not all of them
I'm not sure I have definitely done a
really great job of completely setter
getting my audience so I apologize but
then again I don't because some of you
do like all the videos and if you don't
you know what I mean it is technically
my problem but I still really love
making all the videos that I do make so
it's still fun for me
it's Litzy wants to know what my
favorite TV is at the moment I'm
currently watching I just watch I
watched Luke Cage I watched I have
totally know what it was called but I
watched the most the whole season of it
on Netflix it was called like
containment I don't know what it was it
is a very basic show I kind of just was
editing while it was on the background
but another show that's on HBO is
Westworld which is really really good so
don't only watch the first episode but I
can't wait to watch more Christian won't
know how long does it take to edit a
video well Christian my friend that
could be an hour to six hours to 15
hours a lot of times it takes me a lot
of time to find music for videos so I
spend a lot of time looking for music
and songs before I even actually edit
the video there was a flood that just
real small little tiny bug just flew
right past so really I don't have a set
answer for you they take a long time for
the most part I to cut or dye my hair
what would it be of the blonde because I
heard you do that I didn't actually
might dye my hair a little bit darker
for fall because the blonde ups I'm kind
of over it like I do like having lighter
hair but I think it needs to be just a
little bit darker so that I don't have
to always continue to go in and get it
done I just can't believe how many of
you guys want to know what audio book
I'm listening to and it's crazy because
you guys do know that you can just get a
free audiobook and a 30-day free trial
if you use audible.com/smarter steam
since you guys all want to know what
audiobook of listening to I have just
been listening to this book it's called
a disaster artist on audible I just
finished this yesterday if you guys
aren't familiar with audible basically
audible is an audio book so if you like
books but you don't really like to read
audible is completely the most perfect
solution ever because it'll basically
read the book to you the best part too
is a lot of times the author or your
favorite people who maybe have written
the book actually narrate the book so
this book in particular the disaster
artists I just want to get a show of
hands has anybody ever heard of the room
it's kind of like this crazy cult
classic
by this guy who wrote start in it
directed basically did pretty much
everything in this film his name is
Tommy Wiseau and I had actually done a
few videos with him in the past and this
is before I had any idea of this crazy
concept of this movie called the versus
the other alien don't be scared here do
not touch her unless you want to do now
if you guys are a little bit younger I
don't think it's really appropriate for
your eyes well greg was one of the main
stars of this movie and he actually
wrote this book kind of telling about
the craziness that went on in making the
film the room it's basically one of the
worst movies ever but because it's one
of the worst movies ever it ended up
getting this cult-like following
still to this day video screenings in
Los Angeles I remain listening to this
book was really great because Greg does
an incredible impression of Tommy so
really I only recommend this book if you
are a fan of the room or have any
concept of what it is if you don't know
what it is you might still enjoy the
book but you're probably gonna be a
little bit confused and then you're
gonna want to go see the room and if you
need a suggestion other than that one
yours truly has a book on there to do
you just go to audible.com slash
iJustine and there you'll be able to get
your free trial free book and you guys
will have to let me know what you think
of it I know many of you guys already
have an audible account and I do love
when you guys tweet me what you guys are
currently listening to because they're
actually really good suggestions Nick
wants to know what my thoughts are on
the rumored jet white iPhone so the Jeff
white iPhone was something that I was
really hoping for I think from the
beginning of the announcement because I
love sort of just having that slick
beautiful white as you can see by the
aesthetic here of my setup but here's
what I'm gonna say I absolutely love the
look of my new phone it's the black with
the white cover because something that
used to drive me crazy is whenever I
ever turned my phone off and it would be
the white iPhone face here you would
just have like this black little square
rectangle where the screen is so it
wouldn't all be white so that's why I
decided this time to get the jet black
iPhone but as for the rumors let's see
if this is when this might actually be
jet white iPhone 70s basically just says
that they could be released soon it
speculates that it'll be available to
rule to standard iPhone 7 and the 7 plus
I just feel like at some point I'm down
with it like I think it's cool I will
probably really really really want to
buy I don't want to say a hundred
percent that I'm not gonna buy it
because I tend to have a problem and uh
oh you guys know me hmm
but I really think that the aesthetic of
this phone for me I'm so happy with it
like I think it's really just beautiful
I think the other day I just woke up and
I rolled over and I saw my phone I was
like wow like you look really good RJ
once I know if I'm still doing the
animal crossing new leaf I actually did
just do the update recently and it's
pretty cool there's like this little
camp area a campsite that you can like
go to I have really got to play with it
very much I also haven't added any
amiibo into town yet but that's going to
be really fun I really forgot how much
fun I had with this game I used to play
hurt so much but I also I'm so sad
because I logged in and I still have
like 300,000 or bells to pay off on my
current home loan that's a lot I would
need to pick some cherries and they
better be perfect
um do I think that enough people
protested that Apple would redesign the
new MacBook Pro to include USB I don't
think they will what I feel like Apple
should have done is cool you guys
removed all of the freaking ports but
yet you're still going to call yourself
a pearl machine you should have made
some sort of incredible attachment so
that you could attach it they worked and
just looked and just worked seamlessly
with this new MacBook Pro even if it was
something that took over both all of the
Thunderbolt 3 ports so this is what I'm
recommending people to get so there's
something like this that would clip on
to the side of your MacBook that would
go into both ports to give it sort of
that extra sturdy feel so it doesn't
fall out of your computer while you're
rendering you're doing something if
you've got a bunch of stuff plugged into
it and if it came with sort of like a
MagSafe USBC connector for the charger
that would be so great
I just feel like a lot of people were
extremely upset I think that we do
expect more from Apple because they have
always been the ones to sort of push
that envelope and do things differently
I mean you guys basically had built your
company on thinking differently and
you're not thinking differently you're
thinking like you think you can tell us
this is what we want this is what you
want you're gonna be happy with it
mmm long answer short I think we're all
gonna be okay we're gonna make it work
it's going to be really annoying I do
know that I'm probably going to make
this laptop my main computer I don't
think I'm going to be using a desktop
anymore I think I'm going to figure out
a really cool way to just connect it to
a monitor I don't think I'm going to be
getting the one that they recommended to
get in the keynote because it was really
ugly I didn't like the look of it I
think what I'm going to do is get one of
the ultra wide LG monitors so it's going
to be giving me a lot more space to edit
and work with we'll see I'll keep you
guys updated you guys have any
recommendations please please please
leave those in the comments below
there's a bunch of questions about the
election and about Donald Trump and some
things people are asking about Hillary
and my thoughts I don't really have
anything else to say because you know no
matter what I say nothing is going to be
good enough for anybody
you're gonna have your complaints but
honestly the only thing that I can say
is you guys just have to know that if
anybody ever does try to take advantage
of you or calls you things that are
completely inappropriate or ever does
touch you in a way that is not
appropriate whether it is somebody in
power whether it's our president it's
not a freaking joke like I don't care
who you are
like don't you ever ever disrespect
someone that way like that is what just
absolutely boils my freaking blood
because I've been in those situations
where somebody has power over you and
they try to take advantage of you and
let me tell you what get out of there as
fast as you can and don't ever look back
because there is nothing that is more
important to you and to other people
then your integrity and your dignity so
friends don't lose it I'm fired up now
oh good said to be the good sense man I
love you so much you make me so happy
even a ton of Rage he knew I was getting
upset she came up to make me feel better
okay honey we're gonna go down now okay
that smells a little not good
we've got our instructions will there be
stickers if there's not a Space Gray
Apple sticker in here I'm going to be so
upset I'm going to throw a fit throw a
tantrum if I'm not but they're white so
that'll do